clearly owed one is
um he's an islamist of course
um but I think that there is far too
much focus on that part of what he is if
we really examine what's going on here
it's fascism I mean look at the kind of
um the definition everything in service
of the state the leader becomes
Inseparable from the state and
Inseparable from the nation so and then
you know that system wants to control
everything it wants to control art it
wants to control music culture
discussion media uh business everything
okay this is a definition of fascism and
this is what's happened in Turkey
um and I think you know we really can't
overstay if erdogan wins again and wins
another five years there is going to be
nothing left to democracy in this
country